that weight loss
some actors didn't think they'd make it
through filming while others started to
lose their minds it's not a big deal
it's not a big deal countless roles have
really sent actors through the ringer
tom holland might be one of the most
famous actors in the world but the road
to fame playing spider-man has been far
from easy with all the stress he's
experienced the actors started having
issues sleeping that became full-blown
sleep paralysis which just happens to
coincide with paparazzi nightmares lady
gaga didn't just play patricia gucci
while she was filming the actress
decided to live as if she were her
character all day every day for a full
18 months i was struggling a little bit
with the
with reality using her own real-life
trauma as a trigger to dive into the
role made it that much harder to shake
after filming director ridley scott
became so concerned for gaga that he
urged the actress to pull back on the
intense ride she was putting herself
through being in a marvel movie is
intense no doubt but michael b jordan
went a step further and went a bit
method opting to place himself in
isolation to help him get into
killmonger's psyche but it turned out to
make his job much worse i didn't have a
i didn't have an escape plan either
jordan wound up needing to go to therapy
to help him get out of the dark and
lonely mindset he'd found himself in
while in production you know i wanted to
be in this lonely place
starring opposite jared leto in suicide
squad was rough but it was an even more
traumatizing experience for leto himself
disappearing going into that rabbit hole
was something i never expected with just
about 10 minutes worth of screen time in
suicide squad jared leto went all in and
the repercussions of his intense
approach lasted he even felt a period of
detachment feeling the whole process was
like giving birth out of his prick hole
everybody gets to sit in the chair
he's creepy yet still somehow charming
on screen and as much as joe messes with
the minds of his love interests it was
penn badgley who was struggling on set i
struggled greatly with the the the
conflict of playing such a guy and him
being partly so likable the dark mind of
joe was really rough on badgley's psyche
well i don't think that redemption for
him is like possible we thought playing
harley quinn opposite jared leto was
rough but robbie actually had it much
worse playing tanya harding and i tonya
the actress felt like she was losing her
mind as the line between her life and
her characters became so blurred that
she started experiencing real trauma
especially acting out the abusive
relationship with her on-screen husband
the emotional trauma wasn't all though i
i did herniate a disc in my neck when i
was it wasn't just his body that
struggled playing arthur fleck and joker
sometimes movies get intense
because there are a lot of people in a
small space joaquin phoenix put his body
through a rough time losing 52 pounds
only to end up unable to shake the
obsession around his weight and only
slipping deeper into his character's
psyche
up dude i'm trying to
find something real even after the movie
was done phoenix struggled to shake off
the maddening role
robert pattinson is an actor yes but
when it came to doing the lighthouse and
a few other movies for that matter he
dabbled with some method acting which
could have been fine except for the fact
that he made himself incredibly sick and
as mad as the character he played i mean
lich i would have gone absolutely insane
consuming mud and over drinking were
really hard on his body no surprise
there the actor was regularly vomiting
and fully blacked out during a number of
scenes
he did meet his wife on the show but
game of thrones wound up being a real
struggle for kitt harrington and i think
it
was directly to do with the nature of
the show
by the end of the series harrington felt
a lot of pressure his mental health went
through the ringer and he had to go to
therapy while filming once the series
ended the actor got himself into a
wellness retreat to try to help his
alcohol consumption and stress caused by
the role
it's like a john snow therapy session he
lost 30 pounds he struggled throughout
production then when nightcrawler
finally wrapped the actor continued to
struggle i had to
look
hungry and be hungry recurring
nightmares that included his mentally
and physically deprived character
haunted the actor for a long time
he's already unbelievably ripped but the
rock went full tilt with his training to
play black adam to the point that it
became pretty rough even for the former
wrestler cardio in the morning on an
empty stomach working out even more than
usual the actor dialed in further and
began controlling how much water and
sodium he was consuming depending on
what scene he had to shoot just so he
could push his body to its insanely
toned limits
how hard was it for leonardo dicaprio to
film the revenant full 10 out of 10. i
don't know if i'd go through this one
again this incredibly painful performing
experience left the actor mentally and
physically exhausted desperately needing
time off once the movie was wrapped he
took on unbelievable challenges for the
role especially considering he's vegan
and a raw bison liver as well as
sleeping inside an animal carcass an
intense toll that changed dicaprio
afterwards
american horror story asylum got rough
for sarah paulsen undergoing intense
trauma physically and mentally the
electric shock therapy scene in
particular left the actress really
shaken even though she didn't actually
go through it she felt like she did as
her body shook wildly and broke out and
swept performing over and over again for
the cameras which is really horrifying
and it is a difficult thing to kind of
suspend yourself in while she knew
mentally she wasn't being shocked her
body got traumatized anyway leaving the
actress weeping in corners on set
we felt bad for andy dealing with
miranda's aggressive attitude but really
it was meryl streep who was struggling
the actress opted to live as if she were
miranda priestly and if we know anything
from this heartbreaking scene just
imagine what they're gonna write about
me it was not a good mindset you know
it's the price you pay even her co-stars
could tell she wasn't in a good
headspace instead of celebrating after
rapping streep was struggling to come
out of a total depression
the only thing scarier than seeing
pennywise at work every day is seeing
pennywise involuntarily in your dreams
bill skarsgard was stuck with intense
nightmares of his own character for a
long while after filming like some
people really enjoy and love the
sensation of fear and i get like upset
and angry playing the part was like
being in a very destructive relationship
for skarsgard extreme weight loss to
play fantine didn't just leave anne
hathaway to being physically drained the
toll on her mind and emotions was brutal
it was not a long-term good thing for my
health week's post-production hathaway
was still feeling the effects of
deprivation daily after living off of
lettuce and oatmeal she actually broke
an arm after falling off a bike because
she was so fragile looking back on it
natalie portman realizes that she
probably should have gone to rehab after
filming black swan since at the end of
multiple shooting days the actress
really thought she might lose her life
it was it was very extreme from losing
toenails dropping 20 pounds dislocating
a rib and getting concussed the black
swan process was a nightmare and it took
portman a while to feel okay again kate
winslet nearly drowned working on
titanic with james cameron so it's a bit
surprising that she dove into the deep
end as part of the cast for avatar too a
month of filming and an additional month
of vigorous freediving training saw her
learn to hold her breath for an insane
seven minutes he he got me to seven
minutes 14 what can i say while it was
impressive when she stayed under for
that long it's one special talent she
won't be revisiting anytime soon he
pushed his body losing an extreme amount
of weight for filming the machinist and
at just 124 pounds he wound up needing
to bulk up again to gain a hundred
pounds of muscle to play batman but
binge eating ice cream and pizza wasn't
really the smartest route the actor's
body was in complete shock and bale was
getting sick daily eating nothing but
fruit for a job might seem great but
ashton kutcher didn't realize just how
bad following steve jobs fruitarian diet
would be for his body the performer
wound up being sent to the hospital
twice with pancreatitis because of the
wacky diet my pancreas levels were
completely out of wet all this trauma
stress exhaustion and anxiety from
performing actors jobs are not easy how
far would you go for a roll